في تركيا يعقد قاده ما تعرف بالطاوله
المستديره السداسيه والتي تتكون طبعا من
رؤساء ست احزاب تركيا معارضه يعقدون
اجتماعا للاتفاق على تسميه مرشح للمعارضه
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله امام
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ويجمع اللقاء الذي
يعقد في مقر حزب الخير بالعاصمه التركيه
انقره يجمع مجموعه من الاسماء المعارضه
ومن ابرزهم رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال
الاجدار او بلو رئيس اكبر احزاب المعارضه
التركيه والذي عبر مرارا عن رغبته بالترشح
للرئاسه ويعاد من ابرز الاسماء المطروحه
لمنافسه اردوغان
معنى من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان
زنجلو اهلا بك زيدان خبرنا اكثر عن هذا
الاجتماع والتفاصيل والتوقعات
ال 11 للطاوله السداسيه او زعماء الطاوله
السداسيه بدا قبل حوالي خمس ساعات من الان
في العاصمه التركيه انقره طبعا لا شك ان
القضيه الرئيسيه التي تشغل جمهور المعارضه
هي موضوع المرشح المشترك للمعارضه في وجه
الرئيس او ضد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان هذا الموضوع كان يشغل الاوساط
المعارضه هنا في تركيا لا سيما ان خلافات
نشرت بين اطراف من الطاوله السداسيه بعد
صدور قرار المحكمه التركيه بحبس همم منتصف
ديسمبر الماضي بحادث اكثر من امام اوغلو
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول وحرماني من العمل
السياسي هناك كان جددل همم حول ترشيح
كليجار اوغلو كونه لا يحظى بذات الشعبيه
في الشارع همم كشخصيات مثل الاكرم امام
اوبر رئيس بلديه اسطنبول ومن سوريا واش
رئيس بلديه انقره لكن على ما يبدو اليوم
ان الامور تغيرت ولاسيه مع ان وفد رؤساء
بلديات المعارضه زاره يوم امس كمال كلشدار
اوغلو في مقر حزبه في العاصمه انقره وكان
من ضمن الوفد طبعا منصور هواش رئيس بلديه
انقره واكرم مامون للرئيس بلديه اسطنبول
وابدا هذا الوفد دعمه لترشيح اكرم عفوا
كماك الجدار اوغلو يبدو ان قضيه المرشح
المشترك تسير نحو التوافق على كماك الجدار
اوغلو زعيم المعارضه التركيه هذه نقطه
نقطه اخرى لكن حتى اليوم طبعا في هذا
الاجتماع لن يتم الاعلان عن شخصيه المرشح
من المتوقع ان يتم الاعلان في منتصف
فبراير القادم
زيدان ذكرت انه شعبيته ليست بنفس المستوى
همم لشعبيات همم اخرين منع ربما من
المشاركه ولكن النقطه الرئيسيه اذا ما كان
هناك توافق من قبل الاحزاب فان الولاءات
في الشارع سميل الى ما تريد الاحزاب او لا
[موسيقى]
هذا ما يسعى اليك
زعيم المعارضه يريد ويعتقد انه في حال تم
التوافق عليك مرشح مشترك من قبل جميع
اطراف او نتحدث فقط عن احزاب الطاوله
السداسيه ربما هذا سيعزز موقفه او موقف
زعيم المعارضه في الشارع همم بغض النظر عن
استطلاعات الراي التي كانت تضعه في
المرتبه الثالثه خرف خلف منصور
دخل هؤلاء الانتخابات همم هذه نقطه يعول
عليها لا شيء همم
ويريد كسب الطبقه المحافظه تحديدا من خلال
دعم حزبي المستقبل بعامه احمد داوود اوغلو
وحزب همم
وايضا زعيم همم
ذهب عن بالي الاسم حزب الديمقراطيه
والتقدم علي بابا جان زعيم هذا الحزب
الذين الذين كانوا في حزب العداله
والتنميه وانشق عن هذا الحذر هذا الحزب
يريد كل الجدار اوغلو دعم هؤلاء
وتحديدا الطبقه المحافظه التي تؤيد هذا
الحزبين لمحاوله على يعتقد الموازنه في
اصوات الشارع
رجب طيب اردوغان حظوظه وشعبيته الان والى
اي حد الغزل مع سوريا يمكن له ان يعطيه
دفعه جديده او لا
لا شك في استطلاعات الراي التي كانت تضع
اردوغان في مقابل الجدار اوغلو كانت الكفه
تميل لصالح الرئيس التركي هذا هذه كل
استطلاعات راي كانت اقرتها حتى
استطلاعات الراي من مراكز ابحاث مقربه من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعرض لكن هذا
الموضوع ربما او يعني لا يمكن التكهن به
الان قبل اشهر من الانتخابات المتوقع ان
تكون في الخامس عشر من مايو لا شك ان
خطوات اردوغان اا ولاسيهما في صعيد على
صعيد السياسه الخارجيه تحديدا في الملف
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وايضا اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب ومؤخرا ااه الحديث عن تطبيع
العلاقات مع النظام واعاده اللاجئين همم
فيما يسميها اردوغان العوده الطوعيه الى
سوريا لا شك ان هذا الموضوع ربما يعطي
اردوغان حظوظا في هذه الملفات لكن هناك
عوامل اخرى لا يجب ان نهملها في هذه
الانتخابات وهو العامل الداخلي والتحدث
تحديدا عن العامل الاقتصادي تركيا لا شك
ان عانت العام الماضي من اسوا الظروف
الاقتصاديه وكان هناك اعلى معدل للتضخم
منذ 20 عاما لكن خلال الايام والاسابيع
الاخيره بدات تحدث التضخم وارقام تضخم
بالانخفاض تدريجيا لكن حتى الان ال- اا
ازمه التضخم ما زالت تؤثر في الشارع رغم
كل الاجراءات التي يحاول اردوغان انجازها
قبل وصول موعد الانتخابات